um your kids are your kids like
impressed with what you do still my kids
are still they're seven and N they're
still kind of impressed but they're
they're teetering on I don't care my
yeah my kids it kind of depends on what
it is like when I was doing Thor they
were like this is the coolest job ever
can you just keep doing this we want to
we a superhero yeah yeah and they got to
be like they got to take a turn in the
harness and fly and do flips and stuff
with the stunt team and they were like
this is just the greatest but normally I
think you you might have this they're
just like can you just stay home why are
you going to work oh it's like I've done
like sometimes it's like I've done
nothing and then I was on The Voice with
Ariana Grande and they were like you
know her and I was like okay I was like
cool um I thought this was cool too I'm
obsessed with tattoos don't get them
unless you want 20 um they're they're
very addictive but I I heard that Tao
the director of Thor was actually um
tattooing people did you get one he
didn't even ask me I think he just knows
I'm Aude and just didn't even wait you
don't have one I have none I think I'm
like the last Last Man Standing last
woman standing yes would you get one
would you let him do it if Ty could ask
me probably okay um he's kind of wild
though I don't know I wouldn't trust
taica unless I could see where it was
going cuz I feel like if he did on the
back yeah no I don't trust he didn't
give you one no no but I would totally
let him I am addicted I love them and I
think they're memories so I don't know I
saw momento and I guess got inspired
even though that's a really messed up
movie that's a great movie yes yes it is
a good movie yes
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home